our new bachelorette Jojo  words of wisdom for 25 year old  bachelorette Jojo Fletcher  having him announce it and having  everyone cheer and it was overwhelming  and it was so cool and gave me goose  bumps judges says filming is already  underway enthuse are eating up and  executive brew sir Mike Fleiss is  already releasing titillating treats  offering up this tidbit quote according  to our female crew members this is one  of the hottest cast we've ever had that  confirms the kiss total is 4.5 I would  just want someone who is genuine and  makes me laugh and is my best friend and  ultimately at the end of they just  someone that's gonna love me as much as  I love that one rumored suitor is Jordan  Rogers he's the brother of Green Bay  Packers quarterback Aaron Rodgers